what does it take to be a superhero is
it leaping tall buildings with a single
bound or is it a matter of bravery
against all odds maybe you just need a
superpower no matter how hilariously
terrible that superpower may actually be
for every all-purpose hero like Iron Man
there are a hundred lesser-known heroes
who'd never stand a chance in the
Avengers here are just a few of those
hundreds of forgotten useless heroes and
their crappy superpowers glob Herman for
a while it didn't seem like there is
much of a downside to being a mutant in
the Marvel Universe
aside from being hated hunted and feared
by people who built giant purple murder
robots made of racism until the early
2000s mutants were mostly beautiful that
all changed when the creative team of
Grant Morrison and Frank Quitely arrived
in 2001 to create new x-men as a result
we ended up with some really really ugly
messes one of these misbegotten
characters was glob herman a rotund
teenager whose skin was not only
transparent but also composed of a
substance like paraffin wax
unfortunately for glob paraffin wax is
pretty flammable that's something that
he might have wanted to consider before
joining in with a student riot at xavier
x' and purposely getting set on fire it
turns out that being a giant wax covered
skeleton that's easy to set on fire
isn't exactly a great asset for the
x-men's action-packed pursuits he
survived and surprisingly is still
kicking around the Marvel Universe just
not with the Human Torch kite man it
takes a lot of confidence to commit a
crime in Gotham City odds are that
you'll get multiple concussions from a
guy dressed like a spandex vampire who's
so good at karate they let him in to the
Justice League but maybe you really
think you've got the edge whether it
comes from your freeze gun your
fiendishly clever riddles or if you're
Charles Brown your mastery over Heights
yes
kite man's actual name is Charlie Brown
named for the comic strip character who
famously can't keep a kite in the air
for more than two seconds and if that
wasn't insulting enough the official
guidebook to the DC Universe describes
him as quote a poor leader and even
poorer hand-to-hand combatant ouch
kite man has been revived in modern
Batman comics getting a new catchphrase
kite man hell yeah in a darkly hilarious
origin story that involves his kite
loving son B
poisoned none of this makes him better
at not getting punched half to death by
Batman and everyone around him Ulysses
Solomon Archer writer al Milgram and
artists herb shrimpie and Frank Springer
were fully aware that they were doing
something ridiculously goofy when they
put together Marvel's us one they had to
be us one was after all a licensed toy
comic that was meant to tie into a
remote-controlled big rig you'd like to
get behind the wheel of a ten-ton truck
now UK they did the only thing they
could and created Ulysses Solomon Archer
a kind-hearted trucker who got a metal
plate in his head after a crash and
gained the incredible ability to
telepathically control his 18-wheeler he
couldn't control every semi-truck just
his and he wasn't even the first Marvel
hero with truck powers the generally
forgotten Razorback also had a
remote-controlled big rig pal the
weirdest part is that there's one issue
in the comics 12-issue run that's
narrated by the truck it's even hinted
that the truck might be self-aware still
it's a good enough superpower to give
him occasional cameos in the wider
Marvel Universe showing up anytime
someone needs a trucker who can drive in
outer space which believe it or not
comes up surprisingly often humdinger
Spidey super stories provided no end of
truly weird amazing villains for
spider-man to battle it was after all a
title for young readers where even
characters like Doctor Doom were
presented as goofballs with wacky
schemes and that's a guy who skinned his
old girlfriend to make magical armor
case in point humdinger a would-be
musician whose bad memory led him to
home on stage while this initially went
over pretty well with his audience who
were clearly very drunk or easy to
please his fame quickly went sour and he
decided to hum for evil that's it he
wasn't like super naturally good at
humming or anything he was just really
really annoying and people gave him
money to make him go away it's not
exactly the kind of situation that you'd
think would require intervention from
spider-man but hey the 70s were a weird
time missing man as the co-creator of
characters like spider-man the question
and dr. strange Steve Ditko's
contributions to the history of comic
books are both important and pretty well
chronicled his later creations however
not so much because they got
really really weird the missing man who
made his full debut in 1982 s captain
victory and the Galactic Rangers number
six is one of those weirdos in his
handful of increasingly surreal
appearances his name is variously given
as Syd vain and Syd main and he battles
crime with the uncanny power to not have
a torso he's just a pair of spindly arms
and a couple of cartoony legs capped off
with an unfinished face and fake glasses
if you need more information than that
well there isn't any
it seems along with a body the other big
missing piece of missing man was any
explanation whatsoever for what his
entire deal was oh well thanks for
watching click the grunge icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]